passwords are by far the most common
type of user authentication they are
popular because their Theory makes
perfect sense to individuals and is
reasonably simple to implement for
developers on the other hand poorly
constructed passwords can pose security
flaws a well-designed password-based
authentication process does not save the
user's actual password this would make
it far too simple for a hacker or a
malevolent Insider to access all of the
systems user accounts in this video you
will learn how to crack passwords and
simultaneously try to make your
passwords as Brute Force resistant as
possible let's take a look at the topics
to be covered
today we start by learning about what is
password cracking in
general next we take a look at the
different techniques of password
cracking that hackers use in order to
generate user credentials for hacking
moving on we take a look at the multiple
tools that hackers can use to generate
these hashes and the
passwords finally we take a look at the
steps and the guidelines that users can
follow to prevent their passwords from
being
cracked let's start by giving a basic
idea about password
cracking password cracking is the
process of identifying an unknown
password to a computer or a network
resource using a program code it can
also assist a threat actor in gaining
illegal access to resources malicious
actors can engage in various criminal
activities with the information obtained
through password cracking the procedure
might entail comparing a set of words to
guess credentials or using an algorithm
to guess the password repeatedly
password cracking can be done for
several reasons but the most malicious
reason is in order to gain unauthorized
access to a computer without the owner's
awareness this results in cyber crime
such as stealing passwords for the
purpose of accessing banking information
other non-malicious reasons for password
cracking occur when someone has
misplaced or forgotten a password
another example of non-malicious
password cracking may take place if a
system administrator is conducting test
on password strength as a form of
security test this enables so that the
hacker cannot easily access protected
systems the best way that users can
protect their passwords from cracking is
to ensure that they choose strong
passwords typically passwords must
contain a combination of mixed case
random letters digits and
symbols strong passwords should never be
actual words in addition strong
passwords are at least eight characters
long in many password protected
applications users are notified of the
strength of the password they've chosen
upon entering it the user can then
modify it and strengthen the password
based on the indications of its strength
now that we understand the basics of
password cracking let's go to the basic
techniques hackers use to retrieve
passwords from General
victims asking the customer for for the
password is simple approach to hacking a
fishing email directs the unwar reader
to a counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset that page then
captures their password which the hacker
can subsequently exploit for their own
purpose social engineering influences
the victim to get personal information
such as bank account numbers or
passwords the strategy is popular among
hackers because they realize that humans
are the gateway to vital credentials and
information through social engineering
the employer tried and through tactics
to exploit and influence age-old human
Tendencies rather than devising novel
means to breach secure and Advanced
Technologies it has been demonstrated
that many firms either lack adequate
security or are overly friendly and
trustworthy when they should not be they
allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a so
story a hacker searches a password
dictionary for the correct password in
the case of a dictionary attack password
dictionaries cover many themes and a
mixture of topics such as politics
movies and music groups users failure to
create a strong password is why this
approach efficiently cracks passwords
till today simply said this assault
employs the same terms that many
individuals use as passwords a hacker
can compare the password hash obtained
to hashes of the password diction iies
to find the correct plain text
password now that the passwords have
been hashed the hackers attempt to
achieve authentication by breaking the
password hash they accomplish this by
employing a rainbow table which is a set
of pre-computed hashes of portable
password
combinations hackers can use the rainbow
table to crack the hash resulting in
guessing your password as a result it
retrieves the password hash from the
system and eliminates any need to break
it furthermore it does not necess State
the discovery of the password itself the
breach is accomplished if the hash
matches in a Brute Force assault the
attacker attempts multiple password
combinations until the correct one is
identified the attacker uses software to
automate this process and run exhaustive
password combination in a substantially
shorter length of time with the growth
of hardware and technology in recent
years such programs have been
invigorated it won't be quick if your
password is more than a few characters
lengthy but it will eventually Reveal
Your passw password boot Force assaults
can be sped up by throwing more
processing resources at
them with so many different techniques
coming together to correct passwords
none of them are useful without the
right tools there are a prora of scripts
and Snippets of code that can retrieve
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash digest let's go through
some of these
tools cane and aable is a password
recovery tool for Microsoft operating
systems it allows easy recovery of
various kinds of passwords by sniffing
the network cracking encrypted passwords
using dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks recording Vibe
conversations decoding scrambled
passwords recovering wireless network
Keys Etc are some of the other features
of K enable the latest version is faster
and conail a lot of new features like
ARP poison routing which enables
sniffing on switch L and man in the
middle attacks the sniffer in this
version can also analyze encrypted
protocols such as ssh1 and https while
containing filters to capture
credentials from a wide range of
authentication
mechanisms it also ships routing
protocol authentication monitors and
Route
extractors dictionary and boot Force
crackers are also present along with
common hashing algorithms and several
specific authentications password hash
calculators and other
features John the Ripper is a password
cracking application that was first
released in 1996 for Unix based
computers it was created to evaluate
password strength Brute Force encrypted
hash passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attacks it can use dictionary
attacks rainbow tables and other attacks
depending on the target
type Rainbow Crack is a password
cracking application that uses time
memory trade-off algorithm to crack
password hashes with rainbow tables
rainbow tables make password cracking
more easier and faster than traditional
Brute Force attacks it is like add
containing nearly every possible
password and the pre-calculated hashes
creating this kind of dictionary takes
much more time than cracking a single
hash but after that you can use the same
dictionary over and over again this
procedure might take a long time however
once the table is ready it can break
passwords far quicker than Brute Force
methods with so many tools ready to
naaba passwords there are certain set of
rules users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised let's
cover some of these
guidelines longer passwords are required
making the Brute Force mechanism tougher
to implement longer passwords and pass
phrases have been demonstrated to boost
security significantly however it is
still critical to avoid lenier passwords
that have previously been hacked or that
feature often in cracking
dictionaries this password policy
encourages users to establish passwords
that do not contain personal information
as previously said most users create
passwords utilizing personal information
such as Hobbies nicknames pet or family
member names Etc if a hacker has access
to personal information about a specific
user for example via social media they
will test password combinations based on
that
knowledge password regulations should
compel users to distinguish between
security and convenience users should be
prohibited from using the same password
for all services password sharing
between users ERS including those who
work in the same department or use the
same equipment should be avoided a
single breached password doesn't affect
your other accounts with this
policy some password regulations
necessitate the creation of a pass
phrase rather than a pass word while
pass phrases serve the same objective
the length make them more difficult to
break in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass phases however the L
is much more breach
resistant two- Factor authentication or
2fa can help secure an online account or
even a smartphone tofa does this by
asking the user to provide two forms of
information a password or a personal
identification PIN and a code texted to
the user smartphone or a fingerprint
before accessing whatever is secured
this helps discourage unauthorized
entries to an account without the
original owner's permission at this
point you may wonder why you need a
strong wrong password in the first place
even if most websites are safe there is
still a danger that someone will try to
access or exploit your information a
strong password is among the most
effective ways to protect your accounts
and personal information from hackers
you should follow certain rules and
guidelines while creating a strong
password password managers are also
recommended to help remember the created
passwords for convenience of
usage with that being said let's take a
look at the topics we are covering today
we start by learning about the state of
password cracking in today's world and
why creating strong passwords is an
absolute must for every account next we
will look at some guidelines and rules
that help strengthen passwords and make
password cracking a daunting task for
hackers moving on we understand why past
faes have grown in popularity and are
being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal
information let's start by learning
about why strong passwords have become
an absolute
necessity one of the most common ways
that hackers break into computers is by
guessing passwords simple and commonly
used passwords enable Intruders to
easily gain access and control a
Computing device conversely a password
that is difficult to guess makes it
prohibitively difficult for common
hackers to break into a machine and will
force them to look for another Target
the more difficult the password the
lower the likelihood that one's computer
will fall victim to an unwanted
intrusion many individuals opt to tie
their websites to something they can
readily recall to generally easy
memorable combos however this does not
make the password unique in fact it's
the reverse passwords are handled by 53%
of individuals using their Recollections
and memory with modern computational
standards simple passwords take seconds
and a couple of minutes at at worst to
be completely brute forced according to
Global surveys more than 60% of people
use the same passwords for their
personal and job applications while this
may allow the user never to forget the
password it makes a single point of
failure the only pin to drop if one of
the accounts gets breached all
subsequent accounts are as good as
hacked to further elaborate on how you
can create strong passwords let's go
through some of the
guidelines let's go through some dos and
Don to understand how to create new
passwords for our accounts it is
recommended to keep the password length
at least 12 characters to ensure brute
forcing to be
difficult a combination of upper and
lowercase alphabets is an absolute
necessity when creating strong
passwords it is also recommended to use
numerics along with those alphabets to
create a complicated
password finally special characters help
in making a password much more Brute
Force assistant than any number of
alphabets or letters can make moving
over to the d
section it's absolutely not recommended
to keep Simple dictionary terms such as
computer or even the word password as
your credential because those are very
easy to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack word list similarly changing a
single alphabet or a single character in
a dictionary word does not make it Brute
Force instant considering there are
already algorithms present that can
counter this
tactic using the same character multiple
times in a password also reduces the
strength and makes it easier to crack
for
hackers apart from using single
characters multiple times following
patterns that are present on the
traditional English keyboard such as e w
t y or the line below the main alphabet
such as the ZX X cvbnm Etc make it
easier to guess since these are once
again common combinations that are
present in word list
already finally the most important part
being not using personal information
such as birthdays addresses and other
important information in the passwords
more often than not if a hacker is
trying to break into your account there
has been some amount of research done be
it via social media or any other medium
if they have already this information
present with them breaking into your
account becomes all the more
easier now that you understand how to
create strong password look at how pass
phrases have become prevalent as a
replacement for plain text
passwords a passphrase is a
sentence-like string of words used for
authentication that is longer than a
traditional password easy to remember
and difficult to crack typical passwords
range on an average from 8 to 16
characters while pass phrase es can
reach up to 100 characters or more using
a long fast phrase instead of a short
password to create a digital signature
is one of the many ways that users can
strengthen the security of their data
devices and accounts the longer a
passphrase is the more likely a user is
to incorporate bits of entropy or
factors that make it less predictable to
potential attackers as more websites
applications and services increase the
user security requirements aosr is a
fast and easy way to meet these
criterias let's take a look at some of
the advantages that pass phases have
over common
passwords past phrases are simpler to
remember than just a random assortment
of symbols and characters it's easier to
comprehend a line from your favorite
song or a quotation than a short but
difficult password passwords are
reasonably easy for humans and robots to
guess or crack online thieves have also
Advanced and created Cutting Edge
hacking tools to crack crack even the
most complex
passwords pass phrases are nearly hard
to crack since most efficient password
cracking programs fail at approximately
10 characters as a result even the most
sophisticated cracking tool will be
unable to guess brute force or pre
compute these passwords complies with
password setting rules with ease are
passphrases the usage of punctuation and
upper and lowercase password satisfy the
password complexity criteria most
operating systems and apps support past
phrases phrases of up to 127 characters
are permitted on all major operating
systems including Windows Linux and Mac
as a result for optimal protection you
can use lengthier pass
phrases but when creating a strong
password the major problem people come
across is remembering these passwords or
the pass phrases this is where you can
find a use for a password
manager when you establish accounts or
change passwords password password
managers generate new strong passwords
and they keep all of them in one place
protected by a single strong master
password if you maintain your master
password the manager will retain
everything else including your username
and passphrases and fill them in for you
whenever you sign on to a website or app
on your computer or phone there is no
good memory needed for this this implies
that everyone may use the most recent
suggestions for strong passwords such as
extended phrases symbols grammar and
capitalization password managers enable
consumers to write a single master
password and automatically F each
website with their own unique set of
credentials and not just passwords
credit card information may be stored
securely with several password managers
some others make multiactor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input which is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login
inputs among the global players and
password managers services like bit
Warden keas and ashleen have been
running for years now and are very
worthy recommendations if you want to
get started with password
management hope you learned something
new today if you have any questions
please feel free to ask us in the
comment section below and we will get
back to you as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this and thank you for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling what
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here